It turns out that the Netflix
comedy special "Chris Rock:
Selective Outrage" was selectively edited
by the streamer, but it has nothing to do
with censorship. So why did they choose
to chop up a much-hyped "live" event?
When Will Smith slapped Chris Rock at
the 2022 Oscars ceremony, the incident
immediately became infamous, manifesting
memes, social commentary, and hot takes
from every corner of the internet. Following
"The Slap," Smith publicly apologized to Chris,
explained his actions, and accepted
his 10-year ban from the Academy.
"My behavior was unacceptable, and I'm
here whenever you're ready to talk."
While Smith and his wife, Jada Pinkett
Smith, have been vocal about the incident,
Rock was largely quiet... until now. As
a comedian, it's only natural that Rock
would break his silence on that chaotic night
doing the one thing he knows best: comedy.
The couple were a key part of Rock's new
Netflix stand-up comedy special, "Chris Rock:
Selective Outrage." After detailing
his issues with expensive yoga pants,
ruminating on American politics,
and debating controversial opinions,
Rock spent the last minutes of
his show calling out the Smiths.
Seeing as the world has been waiting for
the comedian's unfiltered thoughts on
"The Slap," Netflix launched the special
with much fanfare, making it their very
first live event to air across the world.
While it was a largely successful effort,
the comedian's performance showed the difficulties
of performing live in front of millions.
Near the end of the special, Rock
delivered a series of jokes about
both Smith and Pinkett Smith, which included
a flub where he confused Smith's 2015 sports
drama "Concussion" for his 2022 slavery-era drama
"Emancipation." In the live stream, Rock said,
"Years ago, his wife said
I should quit the Oscars;
I shouldn’t host ’cause her man
didn’t get nominated for Emancipation,
the biggest piece of sh-t ever! No, not
Emancipation, I f--ked up the joke."
After the mix-up, Rock did that
part of the joke over again:
"She said, me, a f--king grown-ass man,
should quit his job 'cause her husband
didn’t get nominated for 'Concussion.'"
Rock was referencing Jada Pinkett
Smith boycotting the Oscars ceremony
during the peak of the #OscarsSoWhite movement.
Despite Rock's quick correction,
Netflix decided to edit the flub out of
the on-demand version of the live program,
according to The Hollywood Reporter, although
the exact reasons for the cut are unknown.
Was it just an easy fix to make, so the special
would have more polish? Or was the streaming giant
trying to avoid the backlash they'd likely get
for Rock roasting the historical slavery drama,
even if it was by mistake? While Rock
messed up the joke in a really awkward way,
it reportedly still received applause
during the original version of the special.
The Hollywood Reporter confirms that Rock is
aware of the change and has worked with Netflix
to make the necessary edits. Viewers who decide
to watch the comedy special on Netflix's official
website will see a disclaimer just below the set's
title, which reads: "Streamed live and edited."
The special also no longer features
the "N Live" logo on the right-hand
bottom corner. In the final,
edited version of the special,
Rock effortlessly glides through the
joke, never mentioning "Emancipation."
Some fans may be disappointed that Netflix is
undermining the live and unfiltered aspect of
the special, especially after making such
an event out of it. It's unclear if Netflix
would have still edited the special in any
capacity if Rock hadn't flubbed his own joke.
The publication also highlighted how "Chris Rock:
Selective Outrage" had failed to land in
the streaming service's worldwide rankings,
even though it came in at 7th
place in the U.S. Top 10 rankings.